dans les pubs les fuites urinaires
pourquoi dramatiser c'est fréquent non
papa bout un parlons-en
les fuites urinaires parlons-en à 20 ans
non merci en fait
mais si les fuites urinaires tu en as
j'en ai ce n'est pas un tabou mais on
s'est pas vus depuis un mois
j'ai vraiment parler d'autre chose pour
une fois tu vois j'ai pas envie de voir
ça tu vois ça va être pas dans les pubs
mon premier plan clean c'était au mois
un grand costaud à croquer dans la vie
ni dernier plantu c'était waouh c'est
avec un grand coup ce tout une dernier
plan qu'une tu veux dire oui mon plan
qu'une ouais tout plutôt deux fois
qu'une
je te rappelle ok tu veux parler
cornichons la des cornichons pouvoir et
par des gros cornichon comme ça là eh
ben moi j'adore ça
dans les pubs dans la vie c'est plus ça
on le dit plus chez taxe ta gueule ok
c'est pas mal dans les pubs entre amis
en famille
montbellet
sera le plus rapide bon allez la vie
montbellet mais vous allez où il va
jouer reconnaît les auteurs bon bah et
aspeak nous deux j'ai pensé à notre
petit jeu
oui les mots mêlés tiens regarde dit-on
force c'est ça on très bien dans les
pubs sa rare et fait une carrière dans
le web
elle n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour y
arriver et on dirait bien que ce soir sa
nouvelle fille vient de commencer dans
la vie sarah rêvait d'une carrière dans
le web
elle n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour y
arriver et on dirait bien que ce soir sa
nouvelle vie n'arrivera jamais elle va
faire un stage nous rémunérer avec des
tâches ingrates sans avoir une once de
reconnaissance de son patron carrière
dans le web fort mais franchement sarah
aurait dû faire de la comptabilité
ça au moins ça embauche mari je le redis
raquette on est le crédit pour la maison
bonjour je suis votre voisin moi j'ai eu
le tout pour me maison à 1,8
qu'est ce que vous faites pas trop deg
j'ai plus du tout envie d'emmener géant
fatale dans les pubs
[Musique]
vous avez l'énergie de rendre le monde
plus harmonieux avec angie
[Musique]
j'étais dans les pubs
tiens on zero argent de poche pour faire
plein de zéros dépenses 0,3 oui tu
achèteras eurobasket dans la vie tiens
ton héros argent de poche pour faire
plein de zéros dépenses non mais arrête
avec ça je crois que votre 0 maman on va
bientôt rentrer mais papa ça fait déjà
un an que maman tu as quitté la revente
facile avec vendez votre voiture point
fr tendez votre voiture point fr vendez
votre voiture pour faire garder votre
voiture point fr
et couper cette affiche de plus en clair
si vous êtes trompés sur mon salaire par
contre tout acte voit que tu étais
jennifer lawrence regard du budget de la
pub on peut bâtonnets de voir un vrai
concessionnaire on un vieux fond vert
tout péter eckes center heureusement
c'est vendez votre client acer le truc
ça décoiffe je préfère alors en balayant
dans les pubs je peux vous poser
quelques questions oui à toi aussi qui
est la personne la plus curieuse donc
pas dit qui est la personne la plus
curieuse au monde
allez faut répondre vers une phrase en
fait avec des mots tu veux pas parler tu
penses quoi de la situation des gilets
jaunes mais c'est quoi ces interviews
j'ai fait une école du journalisme moi
et c'est quoi ce micro sérieux il se
marre on arrête les enfants j'abandonne
au début mes parents ça les stresse et
d'acheter du neuf
j'ai dû intervenir je leur ai dit les
parents vinci immobilier fouilloux ça
vous dit rien on connaît pas bowles et
les parents vinci immobilier port où ça
vous dirait on connaît parce tu racontes
toi tu as dix ans
si koné quoi l'immobilier franchement
qui se prend-il internet oui bah notre
cabinet nous apprend comment acheter un
appartement sous la mère au foyer mois à
berlin de voir comme c'est quoi ces
gamins-là long dans les pubs papa maman
j'ai quelque chose à vous dire allez que
ça recommence ma musique
vos avis papa maman j'ai quelque chose à
vous dire allez que ça recommence ma
musique très bien jamais les lumières en
verre non allez que ça recommence ma
musique
il fait actuellement 11 degrés à
oulan-bator c'est quoi le message que tu
veux faire passer en plus à l'ex-star
commence ma musique la chanson de lara
clette musique est bon jamais qu'ils ont
le sens en fait ma chérie mais là c'est
pas possible ça arrête
de toi à bord de toi
nettoie à bord
à toi toi